Chaunte is not somebody who believed in ghosts. When her mom died this past May, she remembered seeing her lying there and feeling the finality of it. Like, she's gone. It felt real. But three days later, this thing started happening.
Chaunte并不是一个相信鬼魂存在的人。今年五月她母亲去世时，她记得看到母亲躺在那儿，感受到了一种终结感。就像是，她走了。那种感觉很真实。但三天后，怪事发生了。
I was just laying on the bed, scrolling on my phone, and it felt like somebody was suddenly there. Like, it was a surprise. I was like, oh. Oh, hi.
我当时正躺在床上刷手机，突然感觉好像有谁在那儿。就像是个惊喜。我当时心想，噢。噢，嗨。
It was her mom.
是她妈妈。
And my mom was like, oh, sorry. Sorry to scare you, but just make sure you get to the funeral early so you get a good parking spot. And I was like, oh, OK. Thanks.
然后我妈妈说，噢，抱歉。抱歉吓到你了，但一定要确保早点去葬礼，这样才能抢到个好车位。我说，噢，好的。谢谢。
That was it. No important messages from the other side, not even an I love you.
就这样。没有来自彼岸的重要留言，甚至连一句“我爱你”都没有。
Yeah, that would have been great. But then, she did always really care about good parking spots.
是啊，那本该多好。不过，她生前确实总是很在意好车位。
She lived in Las Vegas. You want to get a spot that's in the shade. That's key. And not saying, I love you? Typical.
她住在拉斯维加斯。你得找个有阴凉的停车位。那才是关键。而且没说“我爱你”？太典型了。
She wasn't a particularly mushy person, so if she had said something more emotional, it wouldn't have been her. And this was her just completely being herself.
她不是一个特别感性的人，所以如果她说了什么更煽情的话，那才不像她。而这正是完全本色的她。
Can I ask, was it frightening?
我可以问一下，这可怕吗？
No, it was more funny than anything else. I was like, you're going to use all of your energy and power from the beyond to tell me about parking.
不，这比什么都滑稽。我就在想，你居然动用从阴间带来的所有精力和能量，就是为了跟我说停车的事。
To be clear, Chaunte didn't actually see her mom. She just felt her presence, like a person sitting beside her, she says. She didn't think too hard about whether it was real or not. Mostly, she just liked it, her mom dropping in like that. She and her mom always really enjoyed each other, made each other laugh, liked hanging out. And her mom died relatively young, 61 years old, from a degenerative disease. She was struggling to speak. She was in a lot of pain. It was nice to think of her past all that.
需要说明的是，Chaunte并没有真正看到她母亲。她说，她只是感觉到了母亲的存在，就像有人坐在她身边一样。她没有深究这到底是真是假。大多数时候，她只是喜欢母亲这样突然造访。她和母亲总是很投缘，互逗开心，喜欢待在一起。她母亲去世时相对年轻，61岁，患有退行性疾病。她那时说话都很困难。她经受了很多痛苦。想到她已经摆脱了这一切，感觉挺好的。
And then it happened a second time a few weeks later. Chaunte was back home in New York City, over 2,500 miles from Vegas where her mom lived and died. How a ghost would get from one part of the country to another is a question that I certainly would have if I believed in ghosts. Does it just jump on a commercial jet? In any case, Chaunte was on her couch.
几周后，这种情况又发生了第二次。Chaunte回到了纽约的家中，距离她母亲生活和去世的拉斯维加斯有2500多英里。如果我相信鬼魂的话，我肯定会纳闷鬼魂是怎么从国家的一头跑到另一头的。它是直接跳上了一架民航客机吗？不管怎样，Chaunte当时正坐在沙发上。
I was, again, scrolling on my phone. I'm just shopping for shoes or something. And again, she just pops up like, oh, you know? And it startled me, and it almost startled her that I saw her, that I recognized her. And she apologizes for startling me. And I'm like, it's OK. Just figure out what you want to say.
当时我又是躺在那儿刷手机。正想买双鞋之类的。然后她又突然冒出来，说，噢，你知道吗？这吓了我一跳，而她看到我发现了她、认出了她，似乎也吓了一跳。她为吓到我而道歉。我说，没关系。你想说什么就直说吧。
And she says, I don't want your dad to be sad. And I said, why don't you tell him that you don't want him to be sad? And she says, but he doesn't listen like you do. And then I thought about how even in life, I was the translator between my parents.
她说，我不希望你爸爸难过。我说，那你为什么不自己告诉他你不希望他难过呢？她说，但他不像你那样听人说话。然后我想到，即使在她活着的时候，我也是父母之间的传话筒。
Oh, is that true?
噢，真的吗？
I was the mediator between them.
我是他们之间的调解人。
She would give you messages to take to your dad?
她会让你带话给你爸爸？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
Did you get a chance to ask any other questions?
你有机会问其他问题吗？
No, I just said, OK, you know, I'll carry the message. No problem.
没有，我只是说，好的，我知道了，我会传达的。没问题。
Wait, didn't you have questions like, what happens to us after we die? Where are you? What is this experience like?
等等，你没有问些诸如“我们死后会怎样？”“你在哪儿？”“那种体验是什么样的？”之类的问题吗？
OK, if she visits again, I'll make sure to ask. It did not even occur to me at the time.
好吧，如果她再来，我一定会问的。当时我根本没想起来。
Really?
真的？
Yeah.
是的。
You know all of humanity would want to know the answer. I mean, I'm speaking on behalf of myself, but also on behalf of all other living people.
你要知道全人类都会想知道答案。我是说，我不仅代表我自己，也代表所有其他活着的人。
This is true. This is true. OK, if she comes again, I will ask her and get back to you.
这倒是真的。这倒是真的。好吧，如果她再来，我会问她的，到时候再告诉你。
Chaunte did deliver the message to her dad, who told Chaunte, yeah, her mom's right. He doesn't listen so well sometimes. The third and last time her mom showed up, again, Chaunte was sitting on the couch.
Chaunte确实把话传给了她爸爸，她爸爸告诉Chaunte，是的，她妈妈说得对。他有时确实不太听得进别人的话。第三次也是最后一次她母亲出现时，Chaunte又坐在沙发上。
This time I was watching TV. And then she decided to appear while I was watching TV, so I had to pause it. And I was like, OK, what is it this time? And she's like, oh, I just wanted to show you what I've been up to and why I haven't been talking to you. I'm taking care of this girl. She always liked taking care of kids, and so that's what she said she's doing right now in the other realm is she's taking care of another kid. And I was like, OK, so you're hanging out with another daughter. I'm here. You can hang out with me.
这一次我正在看电视。然后她决定在我看电视的时候现身，所以我只好把电视暂停。我当时想，好吧，这次又是什么事？她说，噢，我只是想让你看看我一直在忙什么，为什么没跟你说话。我在照顾这个女孩。她一直很喜欢照顾小孩，所以她说她现在在另一个世界就在照顾另一个孩子。我当时心想，好吧，所以你在和另一个女儿待在一起。我在这儿呢。你可以陪陪我。
Wait, did you say that?
等等，你说了吗？
I wasn't going to say it to her.
我没打算对她说。
OK, all right.
好的，没问题。
I just thought it.
我只是心里想想。
Wait, did you have the feeling of, in some ways, she wanted you to give her permission to do that?
等等，你有没有那种感觉，在某种程度上，她希望你批准她那样做？
Yes. She wanted to show me why she hadn't been around, and so that's a little bit permission, but it's also, I'm doing this, so.
是的。她想向我展示她为什么没出现，所以那算是一种许可，但也有一种“我正在忙这个，所以……”的意味。
I'm busy.
我很忙。
I'm busy, yeah.
我很忙，是啊。
But it's actually how her mom was often in life, off busy doing her own thing. And can I say, this is not what Chaunte wants to hear from her dead mother. And she does know what she wants. She wants her mother to say something about her, what she meant to her mom.
但这其实就是她母亲生前的样子，总是忙于自己的事情。我能说吗，这并不是Chaunte想从死去的母亲口中听到的话。她清楚自己想要什么。她希望母亲能说些关于她的事，关于她在母亲心中意味着什么。
I'm super curious. She was such an independent person, and she wasn't particularly expressive with emotion or affection. And so you always wonder like, who am I to you?
我超级好奇。她是一个非常独立的人，对情感或爱意表达得并不多。所以你总是会想，我对于你来说到底是谁？
Yeah, you're saying, you want one more sign from her that she really loved you.
是啊，你是说，你想要她再给你一个信号，证明她真的很爱你。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. And she just is not delivering.
是啊。而她就是没有给出。
She is not delivering.
她确实没有。
This is a well known psychological phenomenon that after somebody dies, they appear in some form that seems very real to the people who are closest to them. They'll see them. They'll hear their voice. They'll feel their presence.
这是一个众所周知的心理现象，在某人去世后，他们会以某种看似非常真实的形式出现在最亲近的人面前。人们会看到他们，听到他们的声音，感觉到他们的存在。
This is a well known thing going back to the 19th century. Freud wrote about it and called it wishful psychosis. And there's a study in the 1970s. It was of 293 Welsh widowers and widows, and it found that nearly half of them said their spouse had returned.
这是一种众所周知的现象，可以追溯到19世纪。弗洛伊德写到过它，并称之为“愿望性精神病”。20世纪70年代曾进行过一项研究。对象是293名威尔士的鳏夫和寡妇，研究发现近一半的人说他们的配偶回来了。
Yeah, that seems to be what has happened. I'm like, is this some sort of self-soothing? Is this some kind of glitch in my brain, glitch of grief, or something like that?
是的，看起来确实发生了这种事。我心想，这是一种自我安慰吗？这是我大脑里的某种故障，一种悲伤的故障，还是别的什么？
Like we want to be haunted.
就像我们渴望被鬼魂缠身一样。
Oh, yeah.
噢，是的。
But if this is you trying to comfort yourself in some way, you're doing such a bad job. I mean, she's not saying the thing you want her to say to comfort you.
但如果这是你在试图通过某种方式安慰自己，那你做得太差劲了。我是说，她并没有说出你想听的那种安慰你的话。
Not at all. Yeah, it's not working.
完全没有。是啊，根本没用。
Well, this is the problem with ghosts is that they don't do what we want them to.
嗯，这就是鬼魂的问题所在，它们不会按照我们的意愿行事。
No, she's not at all.
不，她完全不会。
Today on our program, "The Problem with Ghosts." We expect such specific things from them, and they so rarely deliver. We really do want them to be something they are not, which, frankly, is so unfair. They're dead, and still they're supposed to put up with other people's expectations? Don't we at least get relief from that in the great beyond?
今天我们的节目主题是《鬼魂的问题》。我们对它们抱有如此具体的期待，而它们却很少满足我们。我们真的希望它们成为某种它们并不是的东西，坦白说，这太不公平了。它们已经死了，竟然还被要求忍受他人的期待？难道在伟大的彼岸，我们至少不能摆脱这种束缚吗？
Today on our program, we have stories of all kinds of ghosts, ghosts who've been ignored and misunderstood, famous ghosts, and ghosts who have ghosted those who love them. Yes, they ghosted. Why do you think they call them ghosts? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将讲述各种鬼魂的故事，被忽视和误解的鬼魂，著名的鬼魂，以及那些对所爱之人玩“人间蒸发”的鬼魂。没错，它们玩失踪。你以为为什么叫它们鬼魂？来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。请继续收听。
Act One, The Ghost Industrial Complex. What people want from ghosts in Savannah, Georgia couldn't be clearer. They want a good scare. Ghost tours are a thriving part of the tourism business there.
第一幕，鬼魂工业综合体。在佐治亚州萨凡纳，人们对鬼魂的期待再清楚不过了。他们想要的是一场好的惊吓。鬼魂旅游是当地旅游业中欣欣向荣的一部分。
Still till this day, people passing by her window late in the evening can occasionally still spot her ghost sitting there.
直到今天，深夜路过她窗前的人偶尔还能看到她的鬼魂坐在那里。
Every night in Savannah, the historic district is packed with ghost tours, guides taking people around with ridiculous ghost-detecting equipment, tours in open-top hearses. There's a lot of drinking on these tours. The journalist and podcaster that a bunch of us here at the radio show know, Chenjerai Kumanyika, recently heard from a friend of his, George, who's an eighth generation Savannahan, that something weird is happening on these ghost tours.
在萨凡纳，历史街区每晚都挤满了鬼魂旅游团，导游带着人们到处转，拿着荒谬的鬼魂探测设备，乘坐敞篷灵车游览。这些旅游团里有很多人在喝酒。我们广播节目里的好几个人都认识的一位记者兼播客主持人Chenjerai Kumanyika，最近从他的朋友George那里听说，这些鬼魂旅游团正在发生一些奇怪的事情，George是萨凡纳的第八代居民。
George told Chenjerai that the guides actually talk about the brutal reality of slavery. Chenjerai thought, really? On these tours? They're going for that? Chenjerai was the co-host of the podcast, Uncivil, which documented the typical ways that white Southerners present the history of the South and what they usually leave out, like the violence of slavery. So he wanted to see for himself what was happening and went down to Savannah.
George告诉Chenjerai，导游实际上会谈论奴隶制的残酷现实。Chenjerai心想，真的吗？在这些旅游团里？他们要讲这个？Chenjerai曾是播客《不文明》(Uncivil)的联合主持人，该播客记录了南方白人通常呈现南方历史的方式，以及他们通常遗漏的内容，比如奴隶制的暴力。所以他想亲自看看发生了什么，便去了萨凡纳。
I went on a bunch of these ghost tours. My friend, George, told me to be sure that I went on one called The Spirits and Scoundrels Tour. I pulled up on it at about 10:00 PM on a Saturday night. It was being led by an older white dude dressed like a pirate with baggy pants and a black scarf around his head, silver rings and daggers hanging from his waist. He jingled when he walked.
我参加了好几个这种鬼魂旅游团。我的朋友George告诉我不妨去参加一个叫“灵魂与无赖之旅”(The Spirits and Scoundrels Tour)的团。周六晚上10点左右，我赶上了那个团。团长是一位年长的白人老兄，打扮得像个海盗，穿着宽大的裤子，头上系着黑头巾，腰间挂着银戒指和匕首。他走路时发出叮当作响的声音。
Well, ladies and gentlemen, welcome to The Spirits and Scoundrels Tour. I guarantee you we will be walking on the dead this evening. And as far as I know, we may well be standing on some as I'm speaking.
各位女士先生们，欢迎参加“灵魂与无赖之旅”。我保证今晚我们走的路底下就是死人。而且据我所知，说不定我说话的时候我们就正站在某些死人身上。
As we walked, every once in a while, he would stop our group in front of one of these large mansions and tell us about a murder and some kind of ghost sighting. All of this was totally predictable on a ghost tour and also part of why I'm not into ghost tours. But then the pirate pointed down to these bricks and said they were sunken down in the sidewalk because there were bodies of people buried beneath us.
我们走的时候，他偶尔会停在一座大豪宅前，给我们讲述谋杀案和某种鬼魂目击事件。所有这些在鬼魂旅游团里都是完全可预测的，这也正是为什么我不喜欢鬼魂旅游团的原因。但接着，那个海盗指着地上的砖块说，它们在人行道上凹陷下去，是因为我们脚下埋着尸体。
I told you I was going to have us walking on the dead this evening, didn't I? And by golly, I didn't monkey around by getting you on them either. These bricks we're walking on are the original bricks handmade by the enslaved folks in Savannah. You'll see these all over the historic district.
我说过今晚会让你们走在死人身上，对吧？天哪，我可没在这事上糊弄你们。我们脚下走的这些砖，是萨凡纳的奴隶们手工制作的原始砖块。在整个历史街区你都能看到它们。
And when you do, take a moment to look at them closely because you can often find the indentations of the fingers of the brickmaker. You can see the pinky finger, the index finger, the you-know-what finger. The small size of these indicates the brickmaker was either a woman or a child.
当你看到它们时，花点时间仔细看看，因为你经常能找到砖匠手指留下的压痕。你能看到小指、食指、“那个”手指。这些小尺寸表明砖匠要么是妇女，要么是孩子。
Suddenly, we weren't just talking about ghosts anymore. The pirate had snatched us into this kind of weird Black history archaeology moment. Honestly, it caught me off guard. Keep in mind, people are walking past us with beers in their hands. It's not quite New Orleans, but it's definitely a downtown drinking vibe. The pirate knelt down and held his fingers above the indentations in the bricks.
突然之间，我们谈论的不再仅仅是鬼魂了。那个海盗把我们带入了一种奇怪的黑人历史考古时刻。老实说，这让我措手不及。请记住，人们正拿着啤酒从我们身边走过。虽然不像新奥尔良，但这绝对是市中心的饮酒氛围。海盗跪了下来，把手指放在砖块的压痕上方。
When I find them, I always like to put my fingers in them. I feel like it gives me a connection with the brickmaker.
每当找到它们，我都喜欢把手指放进去。我觉得这让我与砖匠之间建立了一种联系。
When white people acknowledge slavery, I'm not going to tell them, don't do that. But at this moment, I'm not sure I'm buying this connection. This was a tour guide dressed like a pirate, leading mostly white folks who were here to find ghosts. The only other Black guy on the tour was this dude who was maybe in his 30s, and I couldn't help but notice him. Clearly, we were not the target demographic for this tour. When we saw each other, he gave me the nod. I walked over to him.
当白人承认奴隶制时，我不会去告诉他们不要那样做。但在那一刻，我不确定我是否买账这种联系。这是一个打扮成海盗的导游，带着大多是为了找鬼魂而来的白人。团里另一个黑人是一个30多岁的老兄，我不禁注意到了他。很明显，我们不是这次旅游的目标受众。当我们互相看到时，他对我点了点头。我朝他走过去。
How you feel, bruh? You feel like you just learned some Black history? [LAUGHS]
兄弟，你感觉怎么样？你觉得你刚学到了一些黑人历史吗？（笑）
Come on, man. Come on, man.
得了吧，伙计。得了吧，伙计。
He looked directly at me and scrunched up his face. If you looked up, "seriously, bruh?" in the dictionary, this guy's face would be there. I couldn't help but laugh. We both did. His name was Greg.
他直视着我，眉头紧锁。如果你去字典里查“认真吗，兄弟？”，这张脸就会出现在那儿。我忍不住笑了。我们都笑了。他的名字叫Greg。
Soon enough, we had another weird slavery moment on the tour. We stopped in front of a big mansion called the Mercer-Williams House. According to the story, the former owner of the property, Hugh Mercer, told eight of his enslaved people to stand in the front of the house, and then--
很快，团里又出现了另一个关于奴隶制的奇怪时刻。我们在一个叫Mercer-Williams大宅的大宅前停了下来。根据故事，该房产的前主人Hugh Mercer命令八名奴隶站在房子前面，然后——
Ordered them to face to the east, kneel down. And before anybody knew what was happening, is alleged to have pulled his pistol from his pocket, walked behind them-- pop, pop, pop, pop-- shot all eight of them in the back of the head.
命令他们面向东方，跪下。在任何人意识到发生了什么之前，据称他从口袋里掏出手枪，走到他们身后——砰、砰、砰、砰——朝他们的后脑勺开了枪。
As the pirate imitated the sound of the gun, he also acted out the whole thing, pointing his fingers at imaginary Black heads in front of us.
当海盗模仿枪声时，他也演了全过程，手指着我们面前虚构的黑人脑袋。
He then is alleged to have taken two bodies and put them on each corner of the mansion, their heads coming together at the corner, and the foundation stones laid on top of them. This was likely some type of voodoo ritual.
然后据称他拿了两具尸体，分别放在豪宅的每一个角落，让它们的头在角落处会合，并在上面铺上了地基石。这很可能是一种巫术仪式。
After that horrifying detail, he's on to the next thing, like that was just another fun little story. I fell back from the group to walk next to Greg.
在那个可怕的细节之后，他又转到了下一件事，好像那只是又一个有趣的小故事。我从人群中退出来，走到Greg旁边。
Hey, man, hold on. So what'd you think about that, man?
嘿，哥们，等一下。那你觉得那个怎么样，哥们？
He skipped over a whole lot of [BLEEP] just now. You know he did. I'm still stuck on who built the house, the groundwork.
他刚刚跳过了太多[消音]了。你知道他跳过了。我还在纠结究竟是谁盖的房子，地基部分。
And that story about all them enslaved people?
还有关于所有那些被奴役的人的故事？
They have names. Who were they? Why were they shot? That's worth investigating.
他们有名字。他们是谁？为什么要射杀他们？这值得调查。
I wondered the same thing. I wanted to hear more about the Black folks in these stories, not just their deaths. And in every tour I went on, this happened over and over. Guys would breeze through these violent stories of enslaved people getting killed for pure shock value or laughs. Like when the pirate took us to what he said was a slave burial ground, he said the bodies were pretty much just thrown in the dirt, and then he capped that off with a joke.
我也在想同样的事。我想多听听这些故事里的黑人，而不仅仅是他们的死亡。在我参加的每一个旅游团里，这种情况都反复出现。导游们会为了纯粹的震撼效果或笑料，轻描淡写地讲述这些关于被奴役者被杀害的暴力故事。就像那个海盗带我们去他说是一个奴隶墓地的地方时，他说尸体基本上就是扔在土里，然后他用一个笑话作为结尾。
And that's why we think we have such lush, beautiful green grass here.
这就是为什么我们觉得这里有如此茂盛、美丽的绿草。
Other graphic moments of terror or trauma got other punch lines. One tour guide told us about four runaway slaves who were beheaded and joked that their ghosts haunt the square. And if you listen close, you can hear them singing, "I Ain't Got No Body."
其他关于恐怖或创伤的画面细节也得到了其他的笑点。一位导游告诉我们四个逃跑的奴隶被斩首，并开玩笑说他们的鬼魂缠绕着这个广场。如果你仔细听，能听到他们在唱《我没身体》(I Ain't Got No Body)。
I think I was expecting these tours to acknowledge slavery in a way that would check a woke box or something, a few somber sentences acknowledging that slavery was bad before they got back to ghosts. But this was more than that. They were really going in. A lot of this stuff was cartoonish and stereotypical. But intentionally or unintentionally, they were doing something I've called for many times, getting groups of white people to confront the violence and cold-bloodedness of slavery.
我想我原本期待这些旅游团能以一种打钩“觉醒”指标的方式承认奴隶制，在回到鬼魂话题之前，先说几句沉重的句子承认奴隶制是坏事。但这不仅仅是那样。他们真的深入探讨了。很多东西都是卡通化的和刻板印象的。但无论是有意还是无意，他们都在做一件我多次呼吁过的事，让一群白人去直面奴隶制的暴力和冷血。
And why were Southern, mostly white people paying to go on these tours in their time off? It's almost like if you turn critical race theory into a book of ghost stories, all the white folks who hate it would love it. I talked to someone who had an explanation for why this is happening. Tiya Miles is a historian at Harvard, and she stumbled onto a tour like this kind of on a whim.
为什么南方那些大多是白人的人会花钱在休息时间参加这些旅游团呢？这简直就像是如果你把批判性种族理论变成一本鬼故事书，所有讨厌它的白人都会喜欢它。我采访了一个能解释为什么会发生这种情况的人。Tiya Miles是哈佛大学的历史学家，她是在一时兴起下偶然参加了这样一个旅游团。
I was visiting Savannah. It happened to have been a rainy set of days that I walked by a home called the Sorrel-Weed House. As I walked by, I was called and beckoned in by a woman who was standing outside, trying to encourage people to come take a tour.
我当时在访问萨凡纳。那几天正好下雨，我经过一座叫Sorrel-Weed House的房子。当我经过时，外面站着一个试图鼓励人们参加旅游的女人呼唤并招手让我进去。
This tour is presented to Tiya as a historical tour, not a ghost tour. Tiya loves going on history tours.
这次旅游向Tiya呈现为历史之旅，而不是鬼魂之旅。Tiya喜欢参加历史之旅。
I had never heard of this house before, and I was curious. So I went in, I took the tour, and that's where I learned about Molly.
我以前从未听说过这个房子，我很好奇。所以我进去了，参加了旅游，就在那里我了解到了Molly。
Molly is the person at the center of what's probably the most popular ghost story down in Savannah. Her story is the spooky climax of nearly all the tours. The tour guides all stop in front of a big orange mansion with palm trees and Spanish moss. And the way they tell it, this Black woman, Molly, who lived and died in the house, was owned by a wealthy and influential businessman named Francis Sorrel and his wife, Matilda.
Molly是萨凡纳最受欢迎的鬼魂故事中心人物。她的故事是几乎所有旅游团中令人毛骨悚然的高潮。导游们都会停在一座长满棕榈树和西班牙苔藓的巨大橘色豪宅前。按照他们的讲法，这个在房子里生活并去世的黑人女性Molly，是被一个叫Francis Sorrel的富有且有影响力的商人和他的妻子Matilda所拥有的。
Molly is caught up in a love triangle. Francis is having an affair with her. That's the word they use. Only Matilda, his wife, has no idea. Then one night, Matilda walks in on Francis and Molly and catches them in the act. Matilda is so distraught to learn that her husband is cheating that she walks out on the balcony and jumps to her death. Some even believe she was pushed.
Molly陷入了一场三角恋。Francis与她有染。这就是他们用的词。只有Matilda，他的妻子，毫不知情。然后一天晚上，Matilda撞见了Francis和Molly，抓了个现行。Matilda得知丈夫出轨后心烦意乱，走上阳台跳下身亡。有些人甚至认为她是被人推下去的。
A few weeks later, Molly is found dead, hanging from the rafters in the slave quarters. Francis is a suspect in both deaths. Tours all over the city exploit this tragedy by claiming Molly still haunts the house where she was murdered. And remember, because these are ghost stories, they get told with a whole bunch of embellishments, and there are slightly different versions on different tours.
几周后，Molly被发现死在奴隶宿舍的椽子上，是上吊身亡。全市的旅游团都在利用这场悲剧，声称Molly仍然缠绕着她被谋杀的那座房子。请记住，因为这些是鬼故事，所以讲述时添加了大量的润色，并且不同的旅游团有稍微不同的版本。
I will say, though, what's interesting is, Matilda, she was actually really close to Molly. Molly was kind of like an unofficial therapist for her, like a confidante.
不过我会说，有趣的是，Matilda其实和Molly非常亲近。Molly有点像是她的非官方治疗师，就像闺蜜一样。
In some tours, Molly and Matilda come off as if they were lesbian lovers. Here's a letter Molly supposedly wrote.
在一些旅游团里，Molly和Matilda表现得就像她们是女同性恋情人一样。这是一封Molly据称写的信。
"My beloved sister, Matilda, how I yearn for just the slightest whiff of your exquisite perfume."
“我亲爱的姐妹Matilda，我多么渴望能嗅到你那精致香水的一丝气息。”
And one guide went as far as to add a detail about Matilda holding a hot bowl of soup when she walked in on Molly and Francis.
甚至有一位导游增加了Matilda在撞见Molly和Francis时手里拿着一碗热汤的细节。
Goes up the stairs of the carriage house, opens the door with a bowl of chicken noodle in her hand--
走上马车房的楼梯，手里端着一碗鸡汤推开门——
And there's Francois and Molly getting it on.
就看到Francois和Molly正在干那事。
The next thing anyone knew, they heard a terrible cracking noise, and they rushed to the courtyard to go see what it was. And they found Matilda lying dead in the courtyard with a broken neck.
接下来大家知道的是，他们听到了一声可怕的碎裂声，他们冲到院子里去看发生了什么。他们发现Matilda死在院子里，脖子断了。
Molly was found hung in her room a week later.
Molly一周后被发现死在她的房间里，是上吊身亡。
There was only one tour guide who talked about it differently, not coincidentally, the only non-white tour guide we had, a Latina guide named Sarah.
只有一个导游谈论它的方式不同，不是巧合的是，这是我们团里唯一的非白人导游，一个名叫Sarah的拉丁裔导游。
Because of the power structure, that this was someone who was owned by Francis, this was not consensual for both people. This was definitely a rape.
由于权力结构，这是Francis拥有的某人，这并非两人的共识。这绝对是一场强奸。
That's how Tiya saw it, too.
Tiya也是这么看的。
Everyone uses this word affair. To my mind, the way I interpret it was, she had been exploited, she had been abused, and she had experienced terrible pain and suffering.
每个人都用“私通”这个词。在我看来，我的解读是，她受到了剥削，受到了虐待，经历了可怕的痛苦和折磨。
After that first daytime tour where Tiya learned about Molly, she came back for a nighttime tour, which takes you to the room where Molly died.
在那次Tiya了解Molly的白天旅游之后，她又回来参加了一次夜间旅游，带你去看Molly去世的房间。
And so the tour guide described-- my goodness, as I tell you this, I feel my stomach tightening. The tour guide described that she had been found hanging from the rafters of the slave quarters of this particular room. And he took us to this room, and he invited us to go inside.
所以导游描述了——天哪，当我告诉你这些时，我感到胃部紧缩。导游描述说她被发现吊在那个特定房间的奴隶宿舍的椽子上。他带我们去了这个房间，并邀请我们进去。
Tiya stands frozen at the threshold of the door, while the other tourists brushed by her.
Tiya僵在门口，而其他游客从她身边擦肩而过。
They just went on in as if this was just any kind of story. But there was no way I was going inside.
他们就这么走进去，好像这只是任何一种故事一样。但我根本没打算进去。
These were white dudes? The other participants were white folks?
这些是白人男士？其他参与者都是白人？
Everybody was but me.
除了我之外所有人都是。
And they didn't seem to be having the same sense of the gravity of where we were were in the slave quarters of what occurred. They just went in. They didn't have a sort of reverence for the space or anything like that?
他们似乎并没有意识到我们所在的地方是奴隶宿舍，以及发生过什么，那种沉重感。他们就直接进去了。他们对这个空间没有敬畏感之类的吗？
No one seemed to blink an eye. And the tour guide was so charismatic. He was always kind of joking, and he was certainly making light of the story. And he was narrating it as if it were some kind of horror show that people had entered into for fun to get a Halloween scare by choice.
没人眨一下眼睛。那个导游很有魅力。他总是有点爱开玩笑，而且显然是在轻描淡写这个故事。他讲述它的时候，仿佛这只是人们为了好玩、为了万圣节的惊吓而选择进入的一场恐怖表演。
At this point, the tour guide takes out a phone and plays this audio clip that he says was featured on the TV show, Ghost Hunters. They filmed an episode in the Sorrel-Weed House. What Tiya heard was a woman's voice screaming, help, oh, God, help, and the muffled sounds of her crying.
此时，导游拿出一台手机，播放了这段他说曾在电视节目《鬼魂猎人》(Ghost Hunters)中出现过的音频片段。他们在Sorrel-Weed House拍摄了一集。Tiya听到的是一个女人尖叫的声音，救命，噢，上帝，救命，以及她哭泣的闷声。
Part of me was shocked and appalled at what I was hearing. And that same part of me that was shocked and appalled felt just a rush of a sense of protectiveness for Molly, for this young woman who really was a teenager, who was just exploited, abused, used, and then blamed and then killed.
我的一部分被我听到的内容震惊和惊骇。而我内心同样被震惊和惊骇的那一部分，对Molly产生了一种保护欲，对这个实际上还是个青少年的年轻女子，她只是被剥削、被虐待、被利用，然后被指责，最后被杀害。
But another part of me-- and this is, I think, the scholar inside-- had a series of questions running the whole time, questions about, how does this person know what it is that he's telling us? How does he know about Molly? How does he know about the affair? How does he know about the suicide? What is the evidence behind the story?
但我的一部分——我想这是内心的学者——自始至终有一系列的问题，关于，这个人怎么知道他告诉我们的那些内容？他怎么知道Molly的事？他怎么知道出轨的事？他怎么知道自杀的事？这个故事背后的证据是什么？
So what did you decide to do about all of this?
那你决定怎么做？
I decided that I had to research Molly's story and the Sorrel family and this house, and to find out who she was.
我决定我必须研究Molly的故事、Sorrel家族和这个房子，找出她是谁。
She knew it wouldn't be easy.
她知道这并不容易。
If a double death had happened related to a sexual scandal, related to an interracial sexual relationship in the 19th century, the white family would not have been happy to disclose it, right? They would have tried to keep that quiet.
如果在19世纪发生了与性丑闻有关、与跨种族性关系有关的双重死亡，白人家庭不会乐意披露它，对吧？他们会试图保密。
So she started with the more accessible records and tracked down Francis and Matilda and found evidence suggesting she did kill herself, though not in that house. But to confirm that they owned someone named Molly or anyone in that age range, Tiya started out by going to state and local historical collections.
所以她从更容易获得的记录开始，追踪了Francis和Matilda，发现了表明她确实自杀的证据，尽管不是在那所房子里。但为了确认他们是否拥有一个名叫Molly或在该年龄段的任何人，Tiya开始查阅州和地方的历史收藏。
She combed through purchase records of people the Sorrels enslaved, dug through national archives and census records of enslaved folks in Georgia, scoured local newspapers from that time, found letters from neighbors. She even discovered a memoir by one of the Sorrels' sons. And at the end of a year of exhaustive research?
她翻遍了Sorrels家奴役的人的购买记录，挖掘了佐治亚州被奴役者的国家档案馆和人口普查记录，搜寻了那个时代的地方报纸，寻找邻居的信件。她甚至发现了一份Sorrels家儿子写的回忆录。经过一年的详尽研究，结论是？
There was no Molly.
根本没有Molly。
Well, hold up. We got to stop there because, I mean, after-- I mean, you just described to me this whole drama about Molly. And now you're looking in these records, and you don't see any record. Like not--
等等，我们要停在那儿，因为，我是说，在那之后——我是说，你刚向我描述了关于Molly的整场戏剧。而现在你在这些记录中查找，却没看到任何记录。比如没有——
No.
没有。
--like no name of Molly?
——比如没有Molly的名字？
No. No, not a single trace, not a single crumb, nothing. Nothing.
没有。不，连一点痕迹都没有，连一点碎屑都没有，什么都没有。什么都没有。
If Tiya had told me that Molly's story was exaggerated in certain ways, I don't think I would have been surprised. But no Molly?
如果Tiya告诉我Molly的故事在某些方面被夸大了，我想我不会感到惊讶。但根本没有Molly？
It's actually a fiction that somebody had created. And when I realized that, I felt enraged. I felt enraged about the notion that someone had made all of this up.
这实际上是某人编造的虚构故事。当我意识到这一点时，我感到愤怒。有人编造了这一切，对此我感到愤怒。
Tiya was so appalled that she decided to find out if this was happening anywhere else. Turns out plantations and old mansions all around the South give tours like this, and she went on as many as she could. She discovered a whole industry built around fabricated stories, historical sites ginned up with fake tales of murder and torture. And she wrote a book exposing this part of the tourism industry called Tales from the Haunted South.
Tiya对此感到极其震惊，她决定查查这是否在其他地方也在发生。结果发现，南方各地的种植园和旧豪宅都提供这样的旅游团，她尽可能多地参加了这些旅游。她发现了一个建立在编造故事基础上的整个行业，历史遗迹被虚假的谋杀和酷刑故事所粉饰。她写了一本名为《鬼魂南方的故事》(Tales from the Haunted South)的书，揭露了旅游业的这一部分。
Hearing this, I thought back to my tour with the pirate and that story he told about the shooting of eight enslaved people by Hugh Mercer. There's no evidence that happened. And those fingerprints of the enslaved in the bricks we walked on? Bricks like that do exist in Savannah but probably not in that location. But it's not just that so much of this stuff is made up.
听到这些，我回想起了我和海盗的那次旅游，以及他讲述的Hugh Mercer枪杀八名奴隶的故事。没有证据表明那件事发生过。而且我们走过的那些砖块上奴隶的指纹？那样的砖块在萨凡纳确实存在，但可能不在那个位置。但不仅仅是这些东西大多是编造出来的。
The closer Tiya looked at these ghost tours, the more she saw a disturbing pattern in the kinds of stories the tour guides told. They were stories where enslaved folks betrayed their masters or poisoned their masters or seduced their masters. The gore and sensationalism of stuff like this actually hides the realities of slavery by turning the victimizers, their masters, into victims. If you look at them as little moral fables, the message of these stories is that everything would be fine if everyone just stayed in their place.
Tiya对这些鬼魂旅游团研究得越深，就越发现导游讲述的故事中存在一种令人不安的模式。那些故事里，被奴役的人背叛了主人、毒害了主人或引诱了主人。这类故事中的血腥和耸人听闻，实际上通过把受害者及其主人变成受害者，掩盖了奴隶制的真相。如果你把它们看作小小的道德寓言，这些故事的信息就是，如果每个人都安分守己，一切都会很好。
Tiya's book debunking Molly came out in 2015. But when we took the Sorrel-Weed House night tour, Molly's story was still presented as fact, and it was the focus of the tour. I wanted to know how they could justify it. Why are they still telling this lie? The manager of the Sorrel House agreed to talk. His name is Calvin Parker, and I was surprised to learn that he's Black.
Tiya揭露Molly的书中在2015年出版。但当我们参加Sorrel-Weed House的夜间旅游时，Molly的故事仍然被当作事实呈现，而且是旅游的重点。我想知道他们怎么辩解。他们为什么还在撒这个谎？Sorrel House的经理同意接受采访。他的名字叫Calvin Parker，我很惊讶地发现他是黑人。
He's worked at the Sorrel House on and off for 10 years and gives tours himself. But they're the historical tours that happen during the daytime, and they don't mention Molly. These days, he says, Molly only gets mentioned in the nighttime tours. After we discussed some basics about the house, I got right to the point.
他在Sorrel House断断续续工作了10年，自己也带旅游团。但那是白天进行的历史旅游，他们不提Molly。他说，这些天，Molly只在夜间旅游中被提及。在讨论完关于房子的基本情况后，我直接切入正题。
When I took the tour, the stuff y'all are dealing with was so-- really some sensitive and intense stuff. But I got to say, man, it seems like this story about Molly that was a huge part of the tour I took is not true.
当我参加旅游时，你们处理的内容如此——真的是非常敏感和激烈的。但我必须说，伙计，我觉得我参加的旅游中占很大比重的关于Molly的故事是不真实的。
What tour did you take?
你参加的是什么团？
I mean, I took the night tour, is the one I'm talking about.
我是说，我说的是夜间旅游。
OK, well, I deal with more of the history portion of the business. We don't mention that whole story, because we don't think it's as factual as most people think it is.
好的，好吧，我主要负责业务中历史的那部分。我们不提整个故事，因为我们认为它并不像大多数人认为的那样符合事实。
Hold on. Just so I'm clear, you agree that the Molly story that I heard at the tour is a lie?
等等。为了确定，你同意我在旅游中听到的Molly故事是个谎言？
I don't know if it's a lie or not. I think it's something that's been said so many times, it's just stuck.
我不知道那是不是谎言。我认为它是被说了太多次，所以就这么传下来了。
At this point, I realized that this conversation was going to go very differently from what I had expected because I thought Calvin was going to defend the Molly story. Like cite evidence and show me documents. In fact, I'd spent the night before preparing counter evidence, like we were going to trial.
此时，我意识到这次谈话的走向与我的预期非常不同，因为我以为Calvin会为Molly的故事辩护。比如引用证据向我展示文件。事实上，前一天晚上我准备了反证，就像我们要去上庭一样。
Calvin told me he's changed the scripts of the daytime tour so they're factual. But he insisted that, even as the manager, he has no control over what happens in the house at night. He says he was promoted to run the daytime tours four years ago and only the daytime tours.
Calvin告诉我，他修改了白天旅游的稿子，使它们符合事实。但他坚持认为，即使作为经理，他也无法控制晚上在房子里发生的事情。他说他四年前被提升为负责白天的旅游，而且只负责白天的旅游。
The ghost tour portion of this business has always been ran and managed by outside parties.
这项业务的鬼魂旅游部分一直由外部方经营和管理。
He says, this year, for the first time, they haven't had people from these outside companies running that business. So for now, guides have continued giving the ghost tours with no one really supervising them. Calvin says, he's de facto in charge and hoping for a big overhaul.
他说，今年是第一次，他们没有让这些外部公司的人员经营那项业务。所以目前，导游们一直在进行鬼魂旅游，没有人真正监督他们。Calvin说，他是事实上的负责人，并希望能进行一次大整顿。
I have to say, I feel for Calvin. As a Black man, he's in a tough spot as someone stuck navigating a situation created by other people's lies. But I still have this very real feeling that what's going on here is wrong, and I couldn't hold this back.
我必须说，我很同情Calvin。作为一个黑人，他处于一个艰难的境地，因为他不得不处理别人谎言所造成的局面。但我仍然有一种非常真实的感觉，认为这里发生的事情是错误的，我无法按捺住。
If I'm being told that someone was hung in a room in a house, I believe that they should have some verification for that.
如果有人告诉我有人在房子里的一个房间里上吊，我相信他们应该有一些验证。
And I agree with you. But what I'm asking you is, how many tours have you taken in this city?
我同意你的看法。但我问你的是，你在这个城市参加了多少次旅游？
I lost count, maybe five.
记不清了，大概五次。
And how much of those tours you believe is factual?
而且你认为这些旅游中多少内容是符合事实的？
How does that help us understand Molly?
那怎么帮我们理解Molly？
Because you have to understand tourism. You have to understand how these tour guides are trained and how they work. There's a lot of tours in this city that will say things that are not 100%. A lot of the tours in the South are folklore. A lot of the tours in the South were hand down, passed down several times, and sometimes those stories stick with people. If those stories stick with people, I can't help what they say. I can help what I say.
因为你必须理解旅游业。你必须理解这些导游是如何训练的，以及他们是如何工作的。这个城市里有很多旅游团会说些不完全是100%的话。南方的很多旅游都是民俗。南方的很多故事是代代相传的，有时这些故事会留在人们心中。如果那些故事留在人们心中，我无法改变他们说什么。我能改变的是我说什么。
I hear what you're saying, Calvin, about your role, where you're at, how you approach history. But I just wonder if you can understand that it feels like folks have been making money, hundreds of thousands of dollars, off of a lie about a Black woman who was, they're saying, is sexually assaulted for entertainment. And now there's no accountability.
Calvin，关于你的角色、你所处的位置、你接近历史的方式，我听到了你在说什么。但我只是想知道你是否能理解，这感觉像是人们一直在利用一个黑人女性的谎言赚钱，几十万美元，他们说这个黑人女性遭受了性侵犯，是为了娱乐。而现在没有任何问责。
I don't know what you want me to say to that because there is a lot of stories. There's a lot of tourism. This is what happens in this business. And all I can say is, I don't do it, and I can try and change it.
我不知道你想让我说什么，因为有很多故事。有很多旅游。这就是这个行业发生的事情。我能说的是，我不做那件事，我会尽力改变它。
But, bruh, we're talking about the Sorrel House. Do you think there should be some accountability at the Sorrel House for the lie that they've been telling and making money off to sell it to white people?
但是，兄弟，我们谈论的是Sorrel House。你认为Sorrel House是否应该为他们一直在讲的、并利用它向白人赚钱的那个谎言承担一些责任？
I don't think that's the-- I don't know. I mean, that's a good question. Next year, the good thing is, I'm going to be taking control of a lot of that part of the business, and a lot of things will definitely change with me at the helm.
我不认为那是——我不知道。我是说，那是一个好问题。明年，好的地方在于，我将控制业务的很大一部分，在我掌舵下，很多事情肯定会改变。
Are you going to change that part of the-- are you still going to tell the Molly story?
你要改变那部分吗——你还会讲Molly的故事吗？
Oh, no. No, not while I'm there. I can't.
噢，不。不，只要我在那儿，就不会。我不能。
Why not?
为什么不能？
I can't find factual things about the story.
我找不到关于那个故事符合事实的地方。
It's so weird that any of the ghost tours are making this stuff up to shock people because there's no shortage of real horror in Savanna's history, and it's hiding in plain sight. Slavery used to be the city's main business, and you can still see the infrastructure around you.
任何鬼魂旅游团编造这些东西来震撼人们都显得很奇怪，因为萨凡纳的历史从来不缺乏真正的恐怖，而且它就隐藏在众目睽睽之下。奴隶制曾经是这个城市的主要业务，你仍然可以在周围看到其基础设施。
The boats came in at the dock. Negro marts where enslaved people were sold are throughout the city. Don't picture an auction block. These were just stores whose merchandise was human beings, and there were brokers and bankers that funded all of this. People came to Savannah from all over the South to buy enslaved people.
船只停靠在码头。出售奴隶的黑人市场遍布整个城市。不要想象拍卖台。这些只是商店，其商品是人类，有经纪人和银行家资助这一切。人们从南方各地来到萨凡纳购买奴隶。
The problem with these tours is not just that tourists don't get a sense of the actual lives led by real Black people hundreds of years ago. It's also that they don't get any picture of the economic machine that built Savannah, that built this country and made so much of what we live in today. They tell us we're haunted, but they don't say what's really haunting us.
这些旅游团的问题不仅仅是游客没有感受到数百年前真实黑人所过的真实生活。这也是因为他们没有看到建立萨凡纳、建立这个国家并创造了我们今天生活的大部分内容的经济机器的全貌。他们告诉我们我们被缠绕着，但他们没有说真正缠绕着我们的是什么。
Chenjerai Kumanyika. He teaches podcasting and audio reportage at NYU's journalism school. His story was produced by Elna Baker with Valerie Kipnis, Esther Blessing, and George Dawes Greene. George writes about the ghost tours in his new novel, a surprisingly funny thriller called The Kingdoms of Savannah.
Chenjerai Kumanyika。他在纽约大学新闻学院教授播客和音频报道。他的故事由Elna Baker制作，Valerie Kipnis、Esther Blessing和George Dawes Greene协助。George在他的一部新小说《萨凡纳的王国》(The Kingdoms of Savannah)中写到了鬼魂旅游团，那是一部令人惊讶地有趣的惊悚小说。
Coming up, one of the most famous people on the planet tries to get in touch with his mother, who is dead. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，地球上最著名的人之一试图与他已故的母亲取得联系。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Problem with Ghosts," the problem being, of course, that we expect all kinds of things from ghosts, and they usually do not deliver.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Ira Glass。今天节目的主题是《鬼魂的问题》，当然，问题在于我们对鬼魂抱有各种期待，而它们通常无法满足。
We have arrived at Act Two of our program, Act Two, Wedding Crasher. So this next ghost story takes place at a wedding where an uninvited guest shows up. Elna Baker explains.
我们已经到达了节目的第二幕，第二幕，婚礼破坏者。所以下一个鬼魂故事发生在一个不速之客现身的婚礼上。Elna Baker来解释。
The wedding took place on a cold night in February, just one month ago. It was big, celebratory. There was an hour of light food and drinks, and then everyone walked out into the courtyard for the ceremony.
婚礼发生在一个寒冷的二月之夜，就在一个月前。场面盛大，充满了庆祝气氛。有一小时的简餐和饮料，然后所有人走进庭院举行仪式。
The door opens, these double doors, and the first people walking out is my dad holding the groom, and they are holding-- not even holding hands directly. They are holding their elbows intertwined.
门开了，这对双开门，第一个走出来的是我爸爸扶着新郎，他们扶着——甚至不是直接牵手。他们是肘部交缠在一起。
This is Abby. It was her younger sister's wedding, the last of the kids to get married, so it felt like the end of an era. This wedding would be the grand family finale.
这是Abby。这是她妹妹的婚礼，孩子们中最后一个结婚的，所以感觉像是一个时代的终结。这场婚礼将是整个家庭的盛大终场戏。
You have the whole family, the immediate family, the extended family, the grandparents. It's like the closest people of my life as a child are all there.
你有整个家庭，核心家庭，大家庭，祖父母。这就像是我童年时期生活中最亲近的人都在那儿。
But Abby doesn't say hi to any of them. She can't. Abby is standing behind a fence, a little over 50 feet away, on the sidewalk. The uninvited guest, it's her. Abby was disowned by her parents seven years ago. She grew up in Williamsburg, Brooklyn, in the Hasidic community there. It's a tightly knit world of Orthodox Jews in long dresses and black suits and hats, it's own little cultural ecosystem tucked inside New York City.
但Abby没有跟他们任何人打招呼。她不能。Abby站在50英尺外的人行道上的栅栏后面。那个不速之客，就是她。Abby七年前被父母逐出家门。她在布鲁克林威廉斯堡的哈西德派社区长大。那是一个紧密团结的世界，由正统犹太人组成，穿着长裙，戴着黑色西装和帽子，是纽约市内的一个小文化生态系统。
Abby was standing pretty far from the ceremony, but just in case, she wore a face mask, a big coat, and a hat so no one would recognize her. She thought the distance would make it feel less intense, but standing there made her feel like she was at the wedding. It totally threw her off guard.
Abby站在距离仪式相当远的地方，但以防万一，她戴上了口罩、大外套和帽子，这样就不会有人认出她。她以为距离会使那种感觉不那么强烈，但站在那里让她感觉自己就在婚礼现场。这完全让她措手不及。
You can hear the music playing. You can hear the person who is running the ceremony singing in the microphone and so on. So everything is very familiar. But at the same time, I know very consciously that I can't just go down there and be part of it.
你能听到音乐播放。你能听到仪式主持人在麦克风里唱歌，等等。所以一切都非常熟悉。但与此同时，我清楚地知道我不能直接走下去成为其中的一部分。
When Abby first questioned and then left the Hasidic community at 21, it seemed like things would be OK. Her parents stood by her, which was rare at the time, but also made sense. Her family was really close. She'd still come home on weekends.
当Abby在21岁时首次质疑并离开哈西德派社区时，事情似乎会没问题。她的父母支持她，这在当时很罕见，但也说得通。她的家庭非常亲密。她周末还会回家。
But then a few years later, Abby came out as trans. It was a concept so foreign, she says it took over an hour for her father to grasp what she was telling him. But the second he understood, he stopped making eye contact with her. Looking over her shoulder, he said, this means I'm never going to be able to talk to you ever again. Abby says she asked if she could at least say goodbye to her mother. He forbade it.
但几年后，Abby出柜为跨性别者。她说这是一个非常陌生的概念，她父亲花了一个多小时才理解她在说什么。但一旦他理解，他就停止与她进行目光交流。看着她的肩膀后面，他说，这意味着我永远无法再和你说话。Abby说她问是否至少可以和母亲道别。他禁止了。
Not talking to her mother was unfathomable. Before, they'd spoken almost every day. Even though Abby's one of 13 kids, her mom took a special interest in her. And when Abby broke away from Judaism, her mom loved hearing about her life in the outside world. In the weeks and years after Abby was cut off, Abby would call and call trying to reach her mother. One time, her mom picked up the phone.
不和母亲说话是不可想象的。以前，他们几乎每天都说话。尽管Abby是13个孩子中的一个，但她母亲对她特别关心。当Abby脱离犹太教时，她母亲喜欢听她在外面的世界里的生活。在被切断联系的几周和几年后，Abby会打很多次电话试图联系她母亲。有一次，她母亲接了电话。
And I called, and I said, hi, I just want to call you and wish you a Happy New Year and whatever. And then she just asked me, are you coming back? Are you coming home? Which didn't mean physically coming home. It meant spiritually and religiously. And I said, I didn't call to argue. She's like, if you're not coming home, I can't talk to you. And she kept repeating that, almost like a tape recorder, like someone told her to say that.
我打过去，我说，嗨，我只是想给你打电话祝你新年快乐之类的。然后她直接问我，你要回来吗？你要回家吗？这并不是指身体上回家。这意味着精神上和宗教上。我说，我不是为了争论而打电话的。她说，如果你不回家，我就不能跟你说话。她不断重复那句话，就像录音机一样，好像有人告诉她要那样说。
Abby was later told that her father consulted a rabbi about his decision to cut her off, and that this rabbi told him, your child is dead now. When she actually dies, you don't need to sit shiva.
后来有人告诉Abby，她父亲就切断她联系的决定咨询了一位拉比，那位拉比告诉他，你的孩子现在已经死了。当她真正去世时，你不需要坐七天丧(shiva)。
Now, standing outside the wedding, Abby was being forced to watch all the people she'd lost parade in front of her. She studied her father's face. His hair and beard were finally turning white, but she knew that. She'd seen pictures of him online.
现在，站在婚礼外面，Abby被迫看着所有她失去的人在她面前游行。她研究了她父亲的脸。他的头发和胡子终于变白了，但她知道那一点。她在网上看过他的照片。
It's this moment of recognizing that I recognize my dad from photos. My dad, who is alive, I recognize how he looks not because I know him or that I have seen him, but because I've seen photos of him. It is the moment of seeing a person, who, in my head, has this personality of a dad in my childhood, I can't really grasp it. There's this person who is there but isn't. I am here, but I'm not. I am seeing him, but I'm not. I'm there, but I'm not there. And what is happening?
这是认出我从照片里见过我爸爸的瞬间。我爸爸，他还活着，我认出他的长相不是因为我了解他或我见过他，而是因为我见过他的照片。那是看到一个人的瞬间，在我的脑海中，他有着我童年时期爸爸的性格，我无法真正掌握它。这个人就在那儿，但又不在。我就在那儿，但又不在。我正看着他，但又不是。我在那儿，但我不在那儿。到底发生了什么？
Even though Abby knew going to the wedding would be painful, she felt compelled to go because she'd always imagined being there. For years, after they cut her off, she told herself, by the time my youngest sister gets married, we'll have worked through this. I'll be back in the family.
尽管Abby知道去婚礼会很痛苦，但她觉得非去不可，因为她一直想象着自己在那儿。在他们切断联系后的几年里，她告诉自己，到我最小的妹妹结婚时，我们会解决这个问题的。我会回到这个家里。
Throughout the ceremony, Abby kept waiting for her mom to come out with the bride. She knew about when it would happen. She'd been to many weddings. But still, the moment they actually walked out, it caught Abby by surprise. Suddenly, there she was-- her mom, with her sister.
在整个仪式中，Abby一直等着她母亲和新娘一起出来。她知道大约会在什么时候发生。她参加过很多婚礼。但即便如此，当她们真正走出来的那一刻，还是让Abby措手不及。突然，她就在那儿——她母亲，和她妹妹。
They start to circle the groom, and my mom is walking towards me, so to speak. And that was the moment when I remember crying. So she's standing to the right of my sister, holding my sister with her left hand, and in the right hand, holding this candle, almost like imagine a Statue of Liberty moment. It almost felt like she-- thinking back in my head, it wanted to be that moment where she is holding the candle to me or something like that.
她们开始环绕新郎，我母亲向我走来，可以说。那一刻我记得我在哭。所以她站在我妹妹的右边，用左手牵着我妹妹，在右手里拿着这根蜡烛，就像想象中自由女神像的那一刻。回想起来，我脑海里甚至觉得她想要成为那一刻，她拿着蜡烛对着我，之类的。
And to me, that was the most-- that was the most intense moment. Can I play that video, by the way? Because I think the sound gives a sense.
对我来说，那是……那是最激烈的时刻。顺便问一下，我可以播放那个视频吗？因为我认为声音能传达一种感觉。
Will you hold it up?
你愿意把它举起来吗？
They play this song that's been in the family for generations.
她们播放了这首在家族中流传了几代的歌。
The moment of standing there, looking in to my-- looking on the outside to my closest family, listening to a song composed by my great-great-whatever grandfather, I am suddenly feeling like I am a fly on the wall at the moment where you are supposed to be next to the bride and the groom. The most important people at the wedding are their parents and their siblings.
站在那儿的时刻，看着我的——看着外面的我最亲近的家庭，听着我曾曾曾祖父创作的歌，我突然感觉自己像是在你应该在新娘和新郎旁边的那一刻的一只墙上的苍蝇。婚礼上最重要的人是他们的父母和兄弟姐妹。
It's not like I'm not there. I'm there, but I don't have a body. We have a belief, a teaching based on a mystic teaching of the 13th century, that all the ancestors, specifically if they were holy, come down to their weddings as souls, as ghosts, for the lack of a better term, and they're all there. I am suddenly feeling like I am one of those dead ancestors that is coming, that we believe, that we're told is coming to the wedding. I am the ghost.
并不是我不在那儿。我在那儿，但我没有身体。我们有一种信仰，基于13世纪神秘教义的教导，即所有的祖先，特别是如果他们是神圣的，会作为灵魂、作为鬼魂（为了缺乏更好的术语）来到他们的婚礼上，他们都在那儿。我突然感觉自己像是那些来到婚礼的已故祖先中的一员，我们相信，被告知他们会来。我就是那个鬼魂。
So she watches through this chain link fence. It's this literal thing separating them, but even if it weren't there, there'd be no crossing from where she is to where they are.
所以她通过铁丝网观看。这是将他们隔开的字面东西，但即使没有它，从她所在的地方到他们所在的地方也不会有跨越。
My life in general, my parents live seven miles away from me, and it feels like they're so close, but they're so far away. And my dad, frankly, whatever. We're not going to-- yeah. But with my mom, there are so many days I wake up where I just want to ask her what to do about my headache. Or what's a good dish that you think I can make for this holiday? Or I'm having friends over, and I know she would have some great ideas. And all of that comes to the forefront at that moment where I wish I wasn't a ghost. I wish I was seen, not just seeing her.
我的生活总的来说，我父母住离我七英里远的地方，感觉他们离得那么近，但又那么远。我爸爸，坦白说，无论如何。我们不会——是啊。但和我妈在一起，有很多天我醒来时我只是想问她我的头痛该怎么办。或者你认为我可以为这个节日做的菜有什么好的推荐？或者我要请朋友过来，我知道她会有些很棒的点子。所有这些都在那一刻浮现在脑海，我希望我不是一个鬼魂。我希望我被看到，而不是仅仅看着她。
The way you just said, when I wake up, I imagine talking to her, I imagine asking her what I should cook tonight, that's a thing I've felt about people I love who've died.
你刚才说“当我醒来时，我想象着和她说话”，我想象着问她今晚我该煮什么，那是关于我所爱的人中去世的人我感受过的事情。
I don't want to talk to people-- I don't want to talk over people who have literally lost a parent. But to me, it feels worse. I think that's the part where people use ghosts sometimes because it explains-- it talks about something more intense than being dead. The fact that they are alive and I can't talk to them, the fact that they are-- it's like that moment of being so close to them, that would have no doubt been easier if I didn't go. If I wasn't that close to them, it's so much easier.
我不想跟人说——我不想跟那些真正失去父母的人谈论。但对我来说，感觉更糟。我认为人们有时会使用鬼魂，因为它解释了——它谈论的是比死亡更激烈的某种东西。他们还活着而我不能跟他们说话的事实，他们是——这就像那种与他们离得那么近的瞬间，如果我不去肯定会更容易。如果我离他们没有那么近，会容易得多。
Why?
为什么？
Because I don't have to face it.
因为我不必面对它。
Abby brought her girlfriend to watch the wedding with her. It was a strange moment for them both, a kind of bizarro meet the family. These are the people from all the stories I tell you. This was once my life.
Abby带着她的女朋友一起看婚礼。对她们俩来说那是一个奇怪的瞬间，一种荒唐的“认识家人”。这些都是我讲给你的故事里的人。这曾经是我的生活。
What was the last moment of the wedding like? How did you leave it?
婚礼的最后时刻是什么样的？你是怎么离开的？
After the ceremony is over, the bride and groom hold hands and walk back into the venue. And this is the only time that Hasidic couples hold hands in public is at the wedding as they walk off from the ceremony and never again.
仪式结束后，新郎和新娘牵手走回场地。这是哈西德派夫妇在公共场合唯一一次牵手，是在婚礼上他们从仪式走开时，以后再也不会了。
Abby takes one last look at her family, and then she walks away with her girlfriend.
Abby最后看了她家人一眼，然后和她女朋友走开了。
I don't know if it was right away or if, I think-- no, we waited until we left the Hasidic area because we didn't want to hold hands, two women, in the Hasidic area. But once we left, we did, and I remember thinking that I have something none of my siblings do. I can hold the hands of the people I love in public. And I love that for me.
我不知道是立刻走还是，我觉得——不，我们等到离开了哈西德派区域因为我们不想牵手，两个女性，在哈西德派区域。但一旦我们离开了，我们就牵了，我记得我在想我拥有的东西我没有一个兄弟姐妹有。我可以在公共场合牵我所爱的人的手。我很喜欢这一点。
They walk down into the subway together and get on the M train, each stop taking them further and further away from Abby's old life and closer to the place she now calls home.
她们一起走进地铁，坐上M线火车，每一站都带她们越来越远离Abby的旧生活，越来越接近她现在称之为家的地方。
Elna Baker. Abby Stein has a memoir, Becoming Eve, about leaving the Hasidic community and transitioning.
Elna Baker。Abby Stein有一本回忆录，《成为Eve》(Becoming Eve)，关于离开哈西德派社区和转型。
Act Three, Seance Fiction. So this last story happens at a moment in history when lots of people were believing in ghosts. This was the early 1920s. The 1918 flu pandemic had just killed some 50 million people worldwide. Just for scale, that is way more than the number of people who've died of COVID so far, and the number of people on Earth was just a fourth then of what it is now.
第三幕，降神会小说。所以最后一个故事发生在历史上的一个时刻，当时很多人相信鬼魂。那是20世纪20年代初。1918年的流感大流行刚刚导致全球约5000万人死亡。仅作对比，这比到目前为止因新冠死亡的人数要多得多，而且地球上的人口当时只有现在的四分之一。
Add to that the millions of deaths in World War I, and, well, chances are pretty good that if you lived in America or Europe, you were mourning somebody you loved. All that loss led to this peculiar moment that seems kind of unfathomable now, where the idea that ghosts are around us just within reach wasn't some far-fetched or fringy kind of thing. It was mainstream. Sean Cole explains.
再加上第一次世界大战中的数百万死亡人数，好吧，如果你住在美洲或欧洲，你很有可能正在哀悼你所爱的人。所有这些损失导致了这个现在看来似乎不可思议的奇特时刻，即我们周围触手可及的地方有鬼魂的想法并不是什么异想天开或边缘化的东西。它是主流。Sean Cole来解释。
Do you know about Spiritualism? It's this religion, basically, that surged during this period. Believers thought that it's possible to talk to the dead. They attended seances, lots and lots of seances, sit in darkened rooms, often pitch black, holding hands. Furniture would move. You heard voices from beyond.
你知道唯灵论吗？这基本上是一种在这一时期激增的宗教。信徒认为可以与死者交谈。他们参加降神会，很多很多的降神会，坐在黑暗的房间里，通常是漆黑一片，手拉着手。家具会移动。你会听到来自彼岸的声音。
I can't really even begin to describe how pervasive this spiritualist rage was.
我甚至无法开始描述这种唯灵论的狂潮有多普遍。
This is David Jaher, history writer, wrote a book that delves deep into this whole world.
这是David Jaher，历史作家，写了一本书深入探讨了这个整个世界。
You had all these great American scientists who were trying to substantiate proof of psychic phenomenon, proof of an afterlife. The Harvard psychology department were all a bunch of ghost chasers at that time.
你有所有这些伟大的美国科学家试图证实精神现象的证据，证实来世的证据。哈佛心理学系在当时都是一群追鬼者。
Really?
真的吗？
I mean, the head of Harvard psychology was also the head of the American Society for Psychical Research. Charles Richet was a Nobel Prize-winning physicist who coined the term "ectoplasm."
我是说，哈佛心理学系系主任同时也是美国精神研究协会的负责人。Charles Richet是一位获得诺贝尔奖的物理学家，他创造了“灵质”(ectoplasm)这个词。
Ectoplasm, like that stuff in the Ghostbusters movies. Richet was actually a physiologist. And while you may not have heard of Charles Richet or any of the scientists who were spiritualists or who ran with spiritualists, there were these two guys you definitely have heard of, both incredibly famous back then, and even today, who got swept up in this movement in a way that came to really define their lives.
灵质，就像《捉鬼敢死队》电影里的那种东西。Richet实际上是一位生理学家。虽然你可能没听说过Charles Richet或任何唯灵论者或与唯灵论者往来的科学家，但有这两个人你绝对听说过，在当时和今天都极其著名，他们被这场运动席卷，并真正定义了他们的生活。
The first is the world-renowned magician and escape artist, Harry Houdini. At the time of our story, he was grieving the loss of his dearly departed mother. And this was no ordinary mother-son relationship. He wrote romantic letters to her, used to rest his head on her bosom when he was anxious and when he was 35 years old. This, by the way, was before the whole world was talking about the whole Oedipal complex thing.
第一位是世界著名的魔术师和逃脱大师，Harry Houdini。在我们故事发生时，他正在哀悼他已故母亲的损失。这不是普通的母子关系。他给她写过浪漫的信，在焦虑时和35岁时习惯把头靠在她的胸口上。顺便说一下，这是在整个世界讨论恋母情结之前。
And he would never refer to her as his mother. He would always refer to her as his sainted mother or his beloved mother. E.L. Doctorow called Houdini the last of the great mother lovers. So Houdini identified with all the bereaved who were seeking contact with dead loved ones.
而且他从不称她为他的母亲。他总是称她为他圣洁的母亲或他亲爱的母亲。E.L. Doctorow称Houdini为最后一位伟大的恋母者。所以Houdini与所有寻求与已故亲人联系的丧亲者产生了共鸣。
Identified with, but he had a really hard time believing in spiritualism in the same way and for very, very good reason.
与他们产生了共鸣，但他以同样的方式相信唯灵论却非常困难，而且有非常、非常好的理由。
Houdini, before he became a magician, he actually made a living as a fraud medium.
Houdini在成为魔术师之前，实际上是以欺诈性灵媒为生的。
Like a fake medium?
像一个假灵媒？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, no kidding.
噢，不是吧。
So he knew all the tricks. He was, in a sense, the world's expert on psychic fraud. But yet, he was also seeking that one psychic who he could believe was generally in touch with the spirit of his mother. And this is when he befriends Sir Arthur Conan Doyle.
所以他知道所有的花招。从某种意义上说，他是精神欺诈方面的世界专家。然而，他也在寻找那个他可以相信确实与他母亲灵魂保持联系的灵媒。这时他结识了Sir Arthur Conan Doyle。
Yes, the guy who wrote all the Sherlock Holmes stories. He's the other famous-y mcfamous guy in our story. Conan Doyle lost his son, his brother, lots of the men in his family, either in some World War I battle or in the flu pandemic.
是的，写所有福尔摩斯故事的那个人。他是我们故事中另一个著名的家伙。Conan Doyle失去了他的儿子、他的兄弟，他家族中的许多男人，要么是在某次一战战役中，要么是在流感大流行中。
And during the war, he believed he was in contact with the spirits of his lost loved ones through his children's nanny, who supposedly had psychic powers. And she would hold these seances, and he became a believer.
战争期间，他相信他通过他孩子们的保姆（据说有通灵能力）与他失去的亲人的灵魂取得了联系。她会举行这些降神会，而他成为了一个信徒。
And not just a believer, but really the de facto leader of the spiritualism movement. You might be familiar with this part. He traveled all over the place giving presentations and lectures about the virtues of spiritualism, which lent the movement a lot of credibility. Here was this guy who had invented this character who was the pinnacle of rationality and deductive reasoning. Of course, you were going to give him the time of day. And Conan Doyle acknowledged, yeah, there are a lot of fake mediums out there, but there were legitimate ones, too.
不仅是一个信徒，而且确实是唯灵论运动的事实上的领袖。你可能熟悉这一部分。他到各地做演讲和报告，关于唯灵论的美德，这为该运动增添了很多可信度。这里有这个人，他创造了这个理性与演绎推理巅峰的角色。当然，你会给他的时间。Conan Doyle承认，是啊，有很多假灵媒，但也有合法的。
Houdini's mom had already been dead for the better part of a decade when he met Conan Doyle. He presented himself to Conan Doyle as a seeker after the truth, and Conan Doyle thought he could help him talk to his dead mother. They came to really like each other. In 1920, Houdini traveled to the UK to do some shows, and Conan Doyle sent him around to all these mediums that he trusted. But with every one of them, Houdini could see the puppet strings because, again, he had pulled the same stunts himself once upon a time.
Houdini的母亲在遇见Conan Doyle时已经去世了近十年。他向Conan Doyle展示自己是一个寻求真理的人，而Conan Doyle认为他可以帮助他与已故的母亲交谈。他们确实很喜欢对方。1920年，Houdini去英国做了一些表演，Conan Doyle把他送到他信任的所有灵媒那里。但对于每一个，Houdini都能看到傀儡线，因为，再一次，他自己很久以前就玩过同样的特技。
And he claimed to have attended 100 seances in England.
而且他声称在英国参加了100场降神会。
Right. Like one a day or something like that?
对。就像一天一场之类的吗？
Houdini had a tendency to exaggerate. I doubt very much if he attended 100 seances, but he did see a number of these mediums that Conan Doyle recommended, and he struck out. And he told Conan Doyle that, and Conan Doyle thought it was because Houdini's mental state was so turbulent that he basically blocked any kind of possibility of psychic communication when he participated in these seances. And he told Houdini, you can't pursue a spirit the way a terrier pursues a rat. You know, you've got to come in quiet and receptive. And so he thought Houdini was to blame for this.
Houdini有夸大的倾向。我非常怀疑他是否参加了100场降神会，但他确实看到了Conan Doyle推荐的一些灵媒，而他失败了。他告诉Conan Doyle，而Conan Doyle认为那是因为Houdini的精神状态太动荡了，以至于他基本上阻止了任何一种参与这些降神会时的通灵交流的可能性。他告诉Houdini，你不能像梗犬追老鼠那样追逐灵魂。你知道，你必须安静且接受。所以他认为Houdini应该为此负责。
Which, of course, is a conversation you hear in a lot of spiritual houses. If you can't get in touch with the spirit, whether divine or just your cousin, it's because you don't believe well enough.
当然，这是你在许多唯灵论场所会听到的对话。如果你无法与灵魂取得联系，无论是神圣的还是仅仅是你的表亲，那是因为你相信得不够好。
Fast forward a couple of years, 1922, Conan Doyle comes to the states to give some spiritualism lectures, brings his wife along. And they hang out with his new best bud, Houdini, and Houdini's wife. And toward the end of the Conan Doyles' time here, the four of them are at a resort in Atlantic City, just hanging out at the beach or whatever. And the Conan Doyles surprised their magician friend with a suggestion.
时间快进几年，1922年，Conan Doyle来到美国做一些唯灵论演讲，带着他的妻子。他们和他新的好基友Houdini，以及Houdini的妻子一起玩。在Conan Doyles在这里的时间结束时，他们四个人在大西洋城的一个度假胜地，只是在沙滩上玩耍。Conan Doyles让他们的魔术师朋友感到惊讶，提出了一个建议。
Conan Doyle's wife, Jean Doyle, is also a psychic medium, and--
Conan Doyle的妻子，Jean Doyle，也是一位通灵灵媒，并且——
Of course.
当然。
--she has an inspiration this weekend that Houdini's mother is going to come through and present a manifestation of her presence.
——她这周末有了灵感，Houdini的母亲会显现并呈现她存在的表现。
She just comes up with that on her own?
她自己就想到了那个吗？
Apparently. She's hit with this psychic bolt.
显然。她被这道通灵闪电击中了。
OK.
好的。
And so Conan Doyle invites Houdini for a seance. And unbeknownst to the Doyles, this weekend was Houdini's mother's birthday.
所以Conan Doyle邀请Houdini参加降神会。而Doyles不知道的是，这个周末是Houdini母亲的生日。
Sort of an eerie coincidence already. And Houdini, he's agreeable, actually eager. He wrote about this saying, quote, "I was willing to believe, even wanted to believe." They go up to the Conan Doyle's hotel room. Sir Arthur closes the curtains and puts a writing tablet and pencils on the table. This was to be Lady Doyle's mode of mediation, automatic writing.
这已经是一种诡异的巧合了。而Houdini，实际上是同意的，甚至是渴望的。他写道，“我愿意相信，甚至想相信。”他们去Conan Doyle的酒店房间。Sir Arthur关上窗帘，在桌上放了一块写字板和铅笔。这将是Lady Doyle的媒介方式，自动书写。
So the idea is she's in a trance, and she's spontaneously possessed by the spirit that takes hold of her hand, and she's just writing unconsciously.
所以想法是她处于出神状态，并自发地被掌握她手的灵魂所附身，而她只是下意识地写作。
Oh, it's like a Ouija board where the spirit takes your hand and moves it.
噢，就像通灵板，灵魂抓住你的手并移动它。
Yeah, that's a good way of looking at it. It's a very intimate scene. Conan Doyle says a prayer. They're holding hands. It's just complete silence.
是的，那是个很好的观察方式。这是一个非常亲密的场景。Conan Doyle做了个祈祷。他们握着手。只有完全的沉默。
Then Lady Conan Doyle starts writhing around, making all these jerky movements. She pounds on the table, which is the sign that the spirit is present. Lady Conan Doyle asks the spirit, do you believe in God? And then pounds the table three times, which means yes.
然后Lady Conan Doyle开始扭动身体，做出所有这些急促的动作。她捶打桌子，这是灵魂存在的信号。Lady Conan Doyle问灵魂，你相信上帝吗？然后她敲了三下桌子，这意味着是。
So she puts a cross at the top of one of the pads. She asks, are you the spirit of Houdini's mother? Again, she pounds the table three times. And then Houdini lets out this gasp and says, Mama, are you here?
所以她在垫子顶部画了一个十字。她问，你是Houdini母亲的灵魂吗？再一次，她敲了三下桌子。然后Houdini发出这个喘息声说，妈妈，你在这儿吗？
Just thinking about Houdini saying, Mama, are you here? It's really moving.
仅仅想到Houdini说，“妈妈，你在这儿吗？”真的太感人了。
It's really moving, and I think-- I don't know. I can't picture him saying that in any other seance. I think that's expressly something that he was vulnerable enough to say at that moment.
它确实很感人，我想——我不知道。我无法想象他在任何其他降神会中说出那样的话。我想那明确地是他在那一刻足够脆弱地说出的某种东西。
Lady Conan Doyle starts writing furiously. Every time she gets to the end of the page, Sir Arthur tears it off the tablet and hands it to Houdini. Luckily, Houdini held on to the pages after all of this, so we know what's on them. I asked David to read some of what Houdini's dead mother had to say.
Lady Conan Doyle开始疯狂写作。每次她写到页面末尾，Sir Arthur就把它从写字板上撕下来递给Houdini。幸运的是，Houdini在这一切之后保留了这些页面，所以我们知道上面写了什么。我让David读了一些Houdini已故母亲要说的话。
"Oh, my darling, thank God. Thank God at last I'm through. I've tried, oh, so often. Now I am happy. Why, of course, I want to talk to my boy, my own beloved boy. Friends, thank you with all my heart for this. You have answered the--"
“噢，我的宝贝，谢天谢地。终于谢天谢地我通过了。我尝试过，噢，这么多次。现在我很高兴。为什么，我当然想跟我儿子说话，我亲爱的儿子。朋友们，衷心感谢你们所做的一切。你们已经回答了——”
How is Houdini seeming through all of this? Is he emotional during it? Is he--
Houdini在这一切中表现得怎么样？他当时情绪激动吗？他——
According to Conan Doyle, he was completely silent. He seemed on the verge of tears. He looked like somebody who had finally found what they were looking for, to having just beheld a miracle.
据Conan Doyle说，他完全沉默。他看起来濒临泪水。他看起来像个终于找到了他正在寻找的东西的人，刚刚目睹了一个奇迹。
"In this life of mine, it is so different over here, and we see our beloved ones on Earth. That is such a joy and comfort to us. Tell him, I love him more than ever. The years only increase--"
“在我这一生中，在这里太不同了，我们能看到我们在地球上亲爱的人。那是我们如此快乐和安慰的事。告诉他，我比以往任何时候都更爱他。岁月只会增加——”
That's Conan Doyle's version of the story. Houdini is left pale and trembling, a new believer. Houdini's feelings about it become evident about four months later. He writes an article for The New York Sun, saying he's never seen any evidence that anyone can communicate with the dead. Quote, "I don't know of any medium who has not, at some time, been detected in some fraud."
那是Conan Doyle版本的故事。Houdini剩下苍白且颤抖，成了一个新的信徒。Houdini对它的感觉在四个月后变得明显。他为《纽约太阳报》写了一篇文章，说他从未见过任何人能与死者交流的证据。他说，“我不知道有哪位灵媒在某个时候没有被侦测到存在某种欺诈。”
Conan Doyle sees the article and writes a letter to his friend, Houdini, saying-- I'm paraphrasing here-- dude, what the hell? I watched you tear up in front of me. Also, my wife is not a fraud. Houdini writes him back like, dude, that was not my mom.
Conan Doyle看到了那篇文章并给他的朋友Houdini写了一封信，说——我在这里改述一下——兄弟，怎么回事？我看着你在我面前流泪。而且，我妻子不是骗子。Houdini回信说，兄弟，那不是我妈。
The fact that his mother could only read, write, and speak in German, Houdini can't understand how the message from his mother could sound like some Victorian platitude. It's not her voice.
事实上他母亲只能读、写和说德语，Houdini无法理解他母亲的信息怎么听起来像某种维多利亚时代的陈词滥调。那不是她的声音。
Right, Victorian platitude in English.
对，用英语说的维多利亚时代的陈词滥调。
In English. And there's also, it sounds like a spiritualist sermon. "God bless you, too, Sir Arthur, for what you're doing for us, for us over here who so need to get in touch with our beloved ones on the Earth plane. If only the world knew this great truth, how different life would be for men and women. Go on. Let nothing stop you. Great will be your--" There's no biographical reference to anything between Houdini and his mother.
用英语。而且还有，这听起来像是一个唯灵论者的布道。“上帝也保佑你，Sir Arthur，为了你为我们所做的一切，为了我们这里如此需要与地球层面的亲爱之人取得联系的人。如果世界知道这个伟大的真理，人类的生活会有多不同。继续。什么都别阻止你。伟大将会是你的——”没有任何关于Houdini和他母亲之间的任何传记参考。
Including no reference to the fact that it was her birthday. I think she would have mentioned that. Plus, that cross that Lady Conan Doyle put at the top of the page when she started channeling, Houdini is like, ahem, we're Jewish.
包括没有提到这其实是她生日的事实。我想她会提到那个的。加上Lady Conan Doyle在开始通灵时在页面顶部画的那个十字，Houdini是这样的，咳咳，我们是犹太人。
Now, Conan Doyle has responses to all this stuff. First off, there's no language in the afterlife, he says. Maybe a trance medium would come through uttering the exact words of your loved ones in their native tongue, but automatic writers are more translating their thoughts and feelings. We're not taking dictation. And as far as the cross goes--
现在，Conan Doyle对所有这些都有回应。首先，他说来世没有语言。也许一个出神灵媒会说出你亲人母语的确切词汇，但自动书写者更多是在翻译他们的想法和感受。我们不是在听写。关于十字架——
Conan Doyle says his wife does that before she presents any kind of spirit writing because it's to protect from lower influences.
Conan Doyle说他在他妻子呈现任何类型的灵魂书写之前都会那样做，因为那是为了保护免受较低层面的影响。
I always put a cross on top of the page.
我总是在页面顶部画一个十字。
Well, of course. I mean, you don't want dark spirits infiltrating your seance and taking hold of the medium.
好吧，当然。我是说，你不想让黑暗灵魂渗透到你的降神会并掌握灵媒。
No, that'd be terrible.
不，那会很糟糕。
No. The cross prevents that. And Conan Doyle maintains, look, you told me you were walking on air. You told me you were deeply moved. I can't reconcile what you're saying now with what I saw with my own eyes at the time, how you responded and the things that you told me since which indicated that you were convinced.
不。那个十字架可以防止那个。而Conan Doyle坚持认为，看，你告诉我你当时在空中行走。你告诉我你被深深打动了。我无法调和你在当时亲眼看到以及从那以后你告诉我表明你是信服的事情与你现在说的话。
So Conan Doyle's pissed at his friend?
所以Conan Doyle对他朋友生气了？
Conan Doyle was very hurt.
Conan Doyle感到非常受伤。
The Atlantic City seance was the last straw for Houdini. From then on, he wasn't just a skeptic of spiritualism, he was an all out crusader against spiritualism. He would sneak into darkened seances in disguise, shine a flashlight on huckster mediums as they pushed furniture around that was supposed to be moving on its own. He devoted a big chunk of his touring show to just bashing spiritualists, demonstrating exactly how shysters pretended to channel your dead relatives.
大西洋城的降神会是Houdini的最后一根稻草。从那时起，他不仅是唯灵论的怀疑论者，他是一个全面的唯灵论反对十字军。他会乔装打扮溜进黑暗的降神会，当骗子灵媒推动家具时，他会用手电筒照他们。他把巡演中的一大部分精力都用于抨击唯灵论者，展示那些骗子到底是如何假装通灵你死去的亲属的。
He even testified before Congress in favor of a bill that would outlaw fortune-telling for hire. It didn't go anywhere, but the hearing devolved into total mayhem. Mediums and other spiritualists flooded the Capitol, jeering Houdini as he gave his testimony. Security was called in to keep them from laying into each other. He screamed at them, tell me the name my mother called me when I was born.
他甚至在国会作证支持一项取缔有偿算命的法案。它没去成任何地方，但听证会演变成了完全的混乱。灵媒和其他唯灵论者涌入国会大厦，在Houdini作证时嘲笑他。安全部门被叫来阻止他们互相攻击。他冲他们尖叫，“告诉我我出生时我母亲叫我的名字。”
The way Houdini saw it, these so-called psychics, they were just fleecing money from the bereaved, people who were so grief-stricken, of course they were ready to believe anything. It wounded him because he knew how they felt.
以Houdini看来，这些所谓的通灵师，只是在从丧亲者那里骗钱，那些悲痛欲绝的人，当然准备相信任何事。这伤害了他，因为他知道他们是什么感受。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show. David Jaher's book about Houdini's war against people who claim to speak with the dead is called The Witch of Lime Street.
Sean Cole是我们节目的制作者之一。David Jaher关于Houdini对抗那些声称与死者交谈的人的战争的书叫《莱姆街的女巫》(The Witch of Lime Street)。
Our program was produced today by Elna Baker. People who put together today's show include Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Aviva DeKornfeld, Tobin Low, Alaa Mostafa, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Naida Reiman, Charlotte Sleeper, Ike Sriskandarajah, Laura Starcheski, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们的节目今天由Elna Baker制作。把今天节目组合在一起的人包括Phia Bennin、Zoe Chace、Aviva DeKornfeld、Tobin Low、Alaa Mostafa、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Naida Reiman、Charlotte Sleeper、Ike Sriskandarajah、Laura Starcheski、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Matt Tierney、Nancy Updike、Julie Whitaker和Diane Wu。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是David Kestenbaum。我们的执行主编是Emanuele Berry。
Special thanks today to Dr. Jamal Toure, Clyde Washington, Brad Dilling, Jessica Osbourne, Joe Posnanski, David Eagleman, the folks at 1790 in Savannah, and all the tour guides in Savannah who helped us understand the ghost scene there.
今天特别感谢Jamal Toure博士、Clyde Washington、Brad Dilling、Jessica Osbourne、Joe Posnanski、David Eagleman、萨凡纳1790的工作人员，以及所有帮助我们了解那里鬼魂场景的萨凡纳导游。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. You can listen to our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange, which is celebrating its 20th anniversary.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。你可以绝对免费收听我们超过700集的档案。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交换中心提供给公共广播电台，该中心正在庆祝其20周年纪念。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Last weekend, I took him to his first rave. He was so excited to finally try MDMA. And then we got there, and he was so disappointed.
像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生。上周末，我带他去了他第一次狂欢派对。他终于尝试了MDMA感到非常兴奋。然后我们到了那里，他感到如此失望。
There was no Molly.
根本没有Molly。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Ira Glass。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。